من نابرين ينضم الينا الصحه في المختص
بشؤون الروبيه ناصر جبار اهلا وسهلا بك
بدايه ننتقل ونبدا بتصريحات شو لسه الذي
قال ان المانيا تفعل ما هو ضروري لدعم
اوكرانيا ولكنها تريد منع الصعيد النزاع
الذي قد يؤدي الى اندلاع حرب مع روسيا
وحلف شفرات لاصي هل تلاشت مخاوف المانيا
اليوميه اكدت مجددا انها لا تريد ان تصبح
جزءا من الحرب ولكن هذا التغيير في الموقف
الالماني متى دعاياته
اتخذت هذا القرار وفقا للسياسه ارسال
الاسلحه الى اخرى للسياسه الالمانيه كانت
منذ البدايه تقوم على اساسين الاول هو
تنسيق كل صغيره وكبيره مع الحلفاء تحديدا
الامريكين
والحساسيه الثاني
بعد تصريح نحن نراقب هذا النقاش هنا في
برلين منذ اسابيع ويبدو ان ال- همم هذا
الاتفاق جاء في اطار ثنائي الماني يجيء
مؤسف جدا عن هذا القرار لم ياتي في اطار
بيان مشترك بين برلين وباريس لان المان
دائما كانوا عندما يقول يذكرون الحلفاء
يذكرون الفرنسيين قبل غيرهم قبل
الامريكيين اذا القرار ياتي انسجاما مع
هذه السياسه الواضحه منذ بدايه
بموقف الامريكي هناك ايضا انباء حول
استعداد واشنطن لارسال الدبابات ايضا هل
اشترت الموقف الالماني بالموقف الامريكي
همم
دعينا همم
انقل عن التقارير صحفيه رزينه قالت انه
رئيس الحكومه الالمانيه لن يوافق على
ارسال مدرعات اي اسلحه دون ان يقوم من
الامريكي بالمثل عندما جاءت صحيفه
الظهر وقال ان الامريكيين وذكرت الفرنسيه
ايضا مستعدون لارسال عبر مزوان ولكن ايضا
فرنسيين وكلير الى اوكرانيا بعد ذلك
بساعات جاء
الكشف الالماني بان المانيا وافقت على ذلك
ولهذا انا اعتقد ان ما قيل على هذا الكشف
الصحفي انه الالماني اشترته موافقه
الامريكيين يبدو صحيحا لو لم يكن
الامريكيون موافقون على ارسال مثل هذه
الدبابات الى اوكرانيه الى موافق طيب
بالنسبه
تقول بانها همم ان هذه الدبابات لن تكون
قابله للتشغيل في اوكرانيا قبل ثلاثه او
اربعه اشهر على الارجل راح يعني هناك
تناقضات هناك تسريع في قرار ارسال ولكن
هذه الدبابات عمليه التي تكون جاهزه
وعمليه قبل اربعه اشهر كيف نفهم ذلك وما
جاد واذا ارسال هذه الدبابات الان يعني هل
ستحسم المعركه بعد سته اشهر يعني هناك
غموض في همم نوعيه المساعده
اه لست خبيرا عسكريا واعزعم هنا ان
المساله لا تتعلق بالعدد
على المعركه
حق ولكن ايضا بكسر محرم مهم حرب
الاوكرانيا انتقلت الى مرحله جديده واعتقد
ما حدث امس وتطور مهم المساله لا تتعلق ب
14 دبابه المانيه ترسلها المانيا
ترسله دوله اخرى المساله تتعلق من ناحيه
المملكه
التي من هذا الطراز التي تملكها ثلاث عشر
دول اوروبيه وانا اعتقد يعني البركانيون
يقولون على لسان رئيس الاركان في ديسمبر
الماضي محتاج الى 300 دبابه وانا اعتقد
انه هذه الدبابات يمكن توفيرها ولكن في
نهايه المطاف المساله تتعلق بكسر محرم
يتعلق بتصعيد الحرب شكرا جزيلا لك من
برلين ناصر جباره صحفي المختص بالشؤون
الاوروبيه